peu
[Musique]
et
c
m
et
[Musique]
je
ce chevillon
oui
l'iss
un fait divers à paris comme presque
tous les faits divers
celui ci trouvera son épilogue au palais
de justice
[Musique]
on prend
oh
[Musique]
m gaillard
aujourd'hui on est en retard oui venez
dépêchons-nous monsieur gbagbo n'aime
pas tant
on a avec 7 ici
voilà
le jour de pâques 5 avril après le repas
de midi 14 des pensionnaires de la
maison de retraite les glycines sont
pris de malaise
le médecin de l'établissement diagnostic
qu'une intoxication en voir les restes
des repas aux laboratoires qui après
analyse incrimine formellement le gigot
de mouton servi au déjeuner or cette
viande provenait de chez vous cela vous
ne pouvez bollier de chez moi il n'est
jamais sorti que de la viande saine dans
celle qui a été livré aux glycines le 4
avril le l'était pas alors elle n'est
pas de chez moi voyons monsieur guillon
ne vous enfermez pas dans un système de
défense en issue vous êtes le
fournisseur attitré de cette maison de
retraite les factures sont au dossier et
votre employé louis jersey a confirmé
qu'il avait bien livré sa gigot journée
si vous me permettez monsieur mon client
déjà fourni à la police une explication
possible ce sujet je sais m
malheureusement contredite par le
témoignage de gerbe par dylan et pas
avouer sa combine parce qu'il ya une
combine ça peut pas être autrement
enfin monsieur le juge logique
surveiller comme on l'est par l'hygiène
en 35 ans de métier par une histoire du
genre était risqué ma réputation pour
trois malheureux givaudan ne s'en tient
pas debout
non moi je ne démord pas de là la viande
qui est sorti de mon frigo et qui a été
chargé sur le camion s'était de la
viande saine et de premier choix
gris vous prétendez qu'il y aurait eu
substitution au cours du transport
il n'y a pas d'autre solution et il y en
a qu'un qui a pu faire ça c'est cher 1
et dans quel but à aiguilles est en
cheville avec un margoulin parce que on
a beau est un équipe je venais il ya
quand même quelques margoulins
l'abattage clandestin ça existe encore
et ces gens là ont besoin de complices
pour écouler leur camelote
si je comprends bien vous l'accusez de
membres à son compte une partie de la
viande de premier choix que vous lui
confiez et de livrer à la place une
autre viande de provenance et de qualité
douteuse exactement cela supposerait que
le 4 avril il se soit arrêtée au cours
de sa tournée chez un de ces margoulins
pour y procéder à l' échange du gîte ou
or il le nie mais s'il avait la
conscience tranquille tu l'aurais pas
pris la suite j'ai pensé chez lui hier
matin son concierge m'a dit qu'il avait
fait la valise
monsieur merz a été appelé en province
auprès de sa mère malade met aussi vous
voulez prendre connaissance de la lettre
qui m'adresser
merci nous profite d'ailleurs de cette
lettre pour me confirmer ses précédentes
déclarations
si on a besoin de savoir qui l'a fait
que livrer la viande que vous nous aviez
confié eva c'est un menteur asseyez-vous
le 4 avril dernier vous avez bien
d'accompagner louis germain dans sa
tournée de livraison
ben oui d'habitude c'était un maître qui
allait avec lui mais mais le matin il
s'était blessé alors comme dirait
personne de bande et bien préciser nous
comment ça s'est passé
enfin comme jason a dû vous le dire il
ne s'agit pas de ce que monsieur gère ça
a pu venir puisque vous avez vu je fais
la tournée normalement s'est arrêté là
où on avait livré par ailleurs si vous
n'avez fait que livrer n'avait pas
chargé de lyon si avant de partir mais
en cours de route il en est bien certain
oui monsieur le juge puisse poser une
question témoins je vous en prie pendant
tout ce temps je n'ai pas quitté jersey
non alors comment se fait-il qu'il était
seul à bord du camion son retour de
boucherie je m'étais arrêté à la porte
des lilas voir un copain avant ou après
la livraison glycines
ouais on viendrait mettre que cela ne
change rien au problème n'est que ce
témoignage confirme en celui de monsieur
g avare en la version de votre client
bien fragile mais bon dieu vous voyez
pas qui cherchent à le couvrir
je ne sais pas pourquoi ils veulent
couvrir qu'est-ce qui prend 1 pourquoi
tu fais ça vous après changer de temps
il ne posait pas de questions aux
témoins pourquoi c'est mon fils dans mon
bureau c'est un témoin
la meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué je
porte plainte contre gérard avait encore
une fois réfléchissez vous n'apportez
pas la moindre preuve pour étayer votre
cuisine
nous on trouverait la villette c'est un
village tout finit par se savoir
j'ai pensé aussi que votre version
applique la complicité de votre fils de
babel complices les pateras d'aller
faire un tour en prison ça lui apprendra
à vivre
vous savez la prison d'ain jamais rien à
personne gelé ses prisonniers cinq ans
qu'elle a brutalement
non mais vous pensez tout de même pas
que je veux laisser salir la réputation
de la maison parce que vous connaissiez
le tour de la villette et par l'ex
chérie ils entendaient part ça je vous
demande quand même de réfléchir
de toute façon vous inquiétez pas vous
fermerez pas de clients si c'est pas moi
vous défendez ce sera monfils c'est la
vérité il faut le dire tu vois tous les
ennuis que ça pirates on perd le souci
ce fait pas toujours gagner c'est une
histoire comme ça ça suffit pour couler
une affaire c'est pas ton intérêt il
sera le patron un jour
j'espère bien et non c'est toi qui es
lui acheter cette man pourquoi tu à
fouiller dans mes affaires
c'est toi je sais pas toi non alors d'où
elle sort
je me suis payé avec quel argent
eh bien il montre comme ça ça vaut moins
cinq ans pile balle et alors eh ben dis
non avait des économies il t'en donne et
combien pour dire comme eux devant le
juge thunevin répondu et il n'aurait pas
fait ça
bien que cette première bon ben c'est
noté entendue demain
alors on va bien mettre le docteur il
m'a donné 15 jours et l'assurance me
demande un certificat hathaway lettre il
tombe bien bonjour patron est au courant
de ce qui s'est passé
oui d'habitude c'est toi qui fais les
livraisons avec chazal qui doit bien
savoir quelque chose
moi je sais rien il ya un peu par ici
il tombe petite larme et ta gueule mais
moi je te conseille de parler mais je ne
sais rien voilà comment ça se passe bien
avec qu'ils trafiquent je te jure je ne
sais rien écouté mais tu me connais je
plaisante pas pas besoin de tes cartes
de travail et moi je peux te la faire
sauter est ce que tu veux
ensuite c'est tout
c'est peu jusqu'ici vous avez seulement
reconnu que les accusations portées
contre elle par monsieur chevignon
étaient exacts à me suffit pas je veux
savoir qui vous a fourni cette viande
alors je vous ai posé une question
gerzat refusé de répondre
bon pas très cool it sera peut-être plus
bavard vous fatiguez pas allaiter pas
avec moi un long run moins deux parties
a été embêté avait prévu autre chose
alors je lui ai dit t'en fais pas je
n'occuperai tout seul c'est vrai comme
ça vous aviez les mains libres à moi que
venait d'inventer cette version parce
que vous avez peur qu'ils parlent si je
continue à l'interroger
ça sera facile à vérifier
ok vous oui vous avez vous passé
l'après-midi du 4 ème avec des copains
tout ça dans un café à la porte des
lilas lequel le rallye
[Musique]
allez
bonjour chez vous bon je voulais d'abord
qu'une choses soient bien claires entre
nous je ne suis ni votre père ni le juge
d'instruction ni un faiseur de serment
je fais mon métier et mon métier ça
consiste à vous sortir de là si c'est
possible
seulement pour ça faut pas me raconter
l'histoire comme vous en avez raconté
aux juges quand vous lui avez donné ce
faux alibi vous principe lesquelles
elles furent vérifiés
alors cette tournée vous l'avez fait le
nom temps mais vous dit non parce que
sinon vous pour dire comme jersey je
n'étais pas avec lui
bon alors où étiez-vous enfin répondait
vous avez peur de petits de quoi non je
ne le dirai pas
[Musique]
où
oh
il
j'en referai téléphone si métrologie et
ils m'ont dit vous seriez d'accord pour
que la sphère chat lui soient remises au
21e non c'est impossible 21 je peux à
pontoise
rien d'autre votre mère elle rappellera
il vous avez quelqu'un qui vous attend
un mot qui seule lui dame qui n'ont pas
pu dire sur le non madame
voulant prier c'est que puis-je pour
vous
la démarche est assez délicate
confidentielles je voudrais pas que mon
nom soit prononcé
de quoi s'agit-il vous êtes bien
l'avocat de rené chevillon oui d'après
ce que j'ai lu dans les journaux on
l'accuse de complicité dans cette
affaire parce qu'il refuse de dire où il
était l'après-midi de 4 avril
en effet cet après midi là n'a passé
chez moi à 110
mais quelle surprise
bonjour chère madame comment allez vous
remercie mais une éternité
nous sommes vus or quand j'ai une
éternité ce une façon de parler
vous avez toujours 20 ans s'est rhabillé
mais c'est aussi les jolies femmes ont
toujours barton est ce moi mon cher vous
me croirez si vous voulez que le mois
dernier je disais à ma femme
la prochaine fois que je vais à
chantilly je pousse une fois jusqu à
senlis pour la sueur former tout vous
dire enfin ravie de sa va rencontrer je
vous téléphone sans fil au revoir
enchaîne les buts j'aurais pas dû finir
dauphin madame vous comprenez
l'importance de votre témoignage
oui allez je vous accompagne jusqu'au
cabinet de monsieur partout vous n'aurez
qu'à lui répéter ce coup mais comment
voulez-vous ne serait pas avec moi alors
madame non le juge d'instruction attend
les témoins hors de la présence de
l'inculper de son avocat allez bon petit
moi mon cher
je ne voudrais pas être un discret mais
madame haubourdin et votre cliente
ah non non non ah bon je m'étonnais
aussi parce que son mari je peux le dire
était un très très bon ami à moi un
homme remarquable dr haubourdin et en 3
me et fusils vous n'avez pas connu non
non non une personnalité de senlis
conseiller général je pensais même qu'il
aurait fait une carrière politique
beaucoup plus important le sénat
pourquoi pas et puis non il était veuf
quand il l'a épousée beaucoup plus âgé
qu'elle
je me suis laissé dire quelle avait été
sa collaboratrice son infirmière
enfin vous savez ce que c'est le corps
médical pas pauvre edouard j'aimais
beaucoup
et puis craque il ya six mois à
l'infarctus en guise
voyez vous mon cher d'épouser jamais une
femme beaucoup plus jeune que vous
excusez moi de vous quitter si vite je
descends la 12e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
mon
et
ouais
[Musique]
c'est pas le moment l aimant
dans la tête fini avec eux mais pas avec
moi
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que ça va comme ça oui
ici tu as le salé et là tu as le sucre
et c'est très bien c'est parfait
bon alors te dire à madame clairet les
quiches lorraines sont à la cuisine
qu'elle n'oublie pas les faire
réchauffer il suffit de les mettre dans
le four et pour la glace lors qu'elle ne
s'inquiète pas on la livrera dans la
soirée j'ai dix huit heures comme ça
elle sera plus présentable effectue lui
dira aussi qu'elles restent tout ça je
viendrai faire la vaisselle de même
aveugle coûte moins cher le fun ii men
les fans de ménage bon je me souviens tu
veux vraiment pas rester avec nous non
plus ton père si je n'étais pas là pour
lui faire son dîner tu n'entends d'ici
déjà été invité donc ça ça doit être
madame éclairé je vous dérange
on peut manger aux chats faut que je
vous parle j'en ai pas pour longtemps je
montre dans une demi heure à saint
lazare bonbons entre et une seconde où
était mon fils
comment oui si on la laissait sortir ce
qu'il a dit ou il était cette fameuse
après midi j'ai le droit de le savoir
moi aussi à vous avec elle le lui
demander il n'a rien voulu me dire alors
je compte sur vous qui est ce témoin le
connaissez pas monsieur chevillon je
m'étonne que vous me posiez cette
question vous n'ignorez pas que je suis
lié par le secret professionnel
oui mais moi je suis son père c'est pas
pareil et les mineurs je vous en prie
n'insiste pas ça restera entre nous et
puis quoi c'est moi qui paie n'oubliez
pas que je vous en ai laissé une bonne
pincée depuis l'année dernière entre mon
accident l expropriation n'est pas perdu
votre temps alors si vous voulez que ça
continue faut être compréhensif très
bien au moins regretterait
[Musique]
ses manières au caviar
alors c'est vrai tout va bien 2e
dites-moi entre nous et ces petites
sauteries pas seulement pour fêter votre
installation
il commençait déjà à préparer votre
collection conseil de l'eau la raison
faut s'y prendre
quinze ans à l'as vence et encore le
rassurez vous je peux vous puissiez de
ce côté là mais nous avons tous dit ça
merci avec de la gare s'il vous plaît
à
non mais s'il est vraiment nerveux
[Musique]
il n'était entaché mondial unique
eh bien ça ferait huit ans beau dr un
collaborateur efficace
quelquefois prudent qui met toujours gf
je vous avoue que j'ai regretté son
départ d'autant plus qu'ils m'avaient
clairet la perte des secrétaires qui ne
demandait qu elles suivront d'ailleurs
c'était son protégé manquer on m'a
rapporté à ce sujet le mou que fait
courir un excellent confrère cambron
l'aviez sans rien ce ne sera plus tout à
fait qu'en gros lavier plaisant et ce
pont mais on ne la rapporte le site
décidément pas les ragots vont plus vite
que les référés c'est toi qui choisis
tout ça pour madame seul pas une faute
de vous excuser moi il est quelqu'un qui
vous attendent en montrer
[Musique]
bonjour madame je sais bien que c'est
pas une heure mais rené partie de la
maison partie oui s'était disputé avec
son père ça devait arriver ça vous
l'avez pas vu vous savez pas où ils
auraient pu aller comment voulez vous
que je le seul mais bien sûr mon mari
qui n'est pas là et qu'est-ce qu'il faut
que je fasse je ne suis pas il vous l'a
dit que ça n'allait oui j'ai bien essayé
de le retenir mais j'ai quand même pas
les chercher par la police on sera pas
tout de suite
écoutez je demanderai une chose si par
hasard et aux téléphonés vous y passez
vous voir on ne sait jamais et prévenez
moi je vais aller l'attendre à la maison
ça parce que je n'y a fait excusez moi
mais je vous en prie si l'europe ne
manquait pas de m'avertir les bons soirs
[Musique]
talon quoi je parlais à madame
haubourdin s'il vous plaît ah non c'est
inutile oui c'est ça je rappellerai est
bien français qu'est ce que tu me suis
en attente les armes pour les clubs
excusez moi mais le client n'ont pas
peur j'arrive nvidia
non non non et non des moments où ça
nous simplifierait bien l'avis de ne pas
être obligé de notaire
comme disait ma roue mon magnifique et
cruelle métier
[Musique]
c'est très facile pour nous tromper
comprenez par là si vous prenez la
première à gauche ses marques et
chantilly
merci madame a dit qu'elle sera là
jusqu'à 11 heures
[Musique]
mais sait-on avocat oui qu'est ce qu'il
veut c'est moi je voulais voir
oui comme dirait sans doute que ça ne me
regarde pas mais vous devriez rentrer
chez vous votre mère s'inquiète
ma mère elle s'inquiète pas bah oui
c'est ma mère
[Musique]
non
et ce qui compte c'est crohn et soit
heureux et chez moi elle est heureux du
moins il me le dit c'est ce qui est le
plus important l'ont peut-être
maintenant mais plus aucun droit sur lui
on ne revient pas sur un jugement
d'adoption
je sais je sais j'ai déjà essayé autre
fois l'histoire est banale
j'avais 19 ans quand il est né seuls à
paris le père qui ne peut pas m'épouser
mes parents qui me ferment leurs portes
dès sans argent je n'ai pas le choix
alors je les confie à une oeuvre
puis deux ans plus tard quand j'ai voulu
reprendre on m'a dit que c'était trop
tard que ces gens là venaient de
l'adopter mais croyez moi j'ai tout
tenté tout essayé mais quand j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient rien à faire alors j'ai
décidé de l'oublier c'était la guerre
d'algérie je venais de terminer mes
études d'infirmière
alors j'ai décidé de m'engager en 62 je
rentre à paris et un an plus tard je
faisais le docteur haubourdin ya six
mois mon mari est mort j'étais seule une
fois de plus rené allait avoir 18 ans je
connaissais pas je commençais à me poser
des questions comment était-il que
positive j'ai eu envie de le connaître
et comment avez vous retrouvé messagerie
qui étaient ses parents adoptifs
oui au début je prenais attention lui
parler non au revoir ne serait-ce qu'une
fois j'ai remarqué un jeune homme qui
pouvait avoir son nom
je me suis renseigné c'était bien lui
alors je suis revenu deux ou trois jours
plus tard je voulais pris l'habitude il
a fini par s'en apercevoir
d'ailleurs je crois que c'était surtout
ma voiture qui l'attirait 6 du mois le
prétexte qu'il a pris pour me parler je
vais proposer de l'essayer n'a pas
demander mieux
c'est en revenant que je lui ai dit que
j'étais passée jette un os je n'ai pas
les juger en tout cas c'est lui qui
tenait à ce que nous nous revoyons à
l'insu de ses parents
moi je vais pas chercher à l'affluence
et je crois qui n'est pas très heureux
dans cette famille et qu'ils trouvent
auprès de moi la compréhension dont il a
besoin
peut-être aussi certains modes de vie
oui plus agréable quand elle était
naturelle qui viennent se réfugier à toi
de moi je n'ai pas le renvoyer au milieu
de la nuit
[Applaudissements]
non mais ce matin là bas vous a été très
imprudente
je tiens à vous mettre en garde tous
risques graves ennuis enfin vous pensez
bien que ses parents vont le faire
rechercher une retrouvera telle
explication donnez-vous à lons croyez
moi dans votre propre intérêt qu'il
rentrait chez lui le plus tôt sera le
mieux
et s'il ne veut pas
[Musique]
je voudrais pas vous les 15 ou 1 je vous
dérange vous avez une livraison fin du
tout je mets ça à cause du brouillard
qui bouge tellement de charbon dans
maintenant que moi j'ai plus qu'à
balayer ça marche ça va bien merci ma
partie bonjour les premières bauer a bon
dos la wii d'abord je suis toujours de
bonne humeur quand tu viens manger à la
maison je produis bonjour m'étais jamais
dit bonjour je leur ai dit merde
prévenir plus coûteux canard qu'on la
joue tout le temps qu'il est revenu
c'est qu'elle joue dans le couloir j'ai
failli me croise une jambe à entendre la
proposerai à savoir qu'il sait pas
encore si pellan poule de la minute on y
voit un oui mais qu'est ce que tu as a
tool te regarde et à moncton il était
pressé tu vas au palais non non vous
donne un coup de téléphone mais ne le
fera que si on prend pas trop mal non
merci à louis qu'est même cheville on
n'a pas téléphoné à m et ciel appellent
non plutôt une antienne de l'émotion
numéro fois je vois vraiment pas
pourquoi vous continuez à vous occuper
des gens là après tout vous êtes un
vainqueur n'est pas un saint bernard
dans écouter clairière vous en prie je
vous demande pas votre avis je demande
un numéro très bien j'avais eu 200 2 38
16 38 16
merci sur un ton et un secrétaire
adjoint michel pas vrai comme ça je
dirais prendre des gants vous avez les
mains sales
c'est vrai ça elle est pourtant bien
aimable même car eh oui c'est le moyen
petit peu trop tendance à considérer
qu'elle sait mieux que moi ce que j'ai à
faire
mais remarque d'un côté tu as raison
faut jamais se laisser commandé par les
femmes elles m'ont plutôt à débarrasser
tiens prends les assiettes amène les
cuisines et prétentions bon pour les
corses étaient dacia tu ferais mieux de
t'occuper de servir le café
alors madame chevillon à laquelle sera
t-elle un non merci
[Musique]
bonjour m vous avez du nouveau je veux
les voir si rhône étaient rentrés aux
non non il est toujours pas bon
ai passé toute la nuit à attendre je
pouvais pas dormir je pensais à tout ça
je me disais
c'était de ma faute je vais vous ça
faisait 13 ans qu'on était marié canton
à adopter
au moins il y avait longtemps que je
voulais mais mon mari c'était pas son
idée il voulait pas comme ils disaient
d'un fils qui sort d'on ne sait pas où
et puis j'ai tellement insisté qu'il a
fini par céder
la condition que ce soit un garçon
remarquez ça se comprend c'est mieux
d'un commerce pour garder le nom mais au
fond c'est bien qu'ils en voulaient pas
il a dit oui pour faire plaisir et je
suis sûr que le petit l'a bien senti que
son père accepte et pas comme un fils et
tous deux venus de là et s'ils entendent
pas maintenant et bien dans mon idée
c'est venu de là
et moi ça me rend malade parce que ce
qu'ils l'aiment comme un vrai fils on
met lui aussi madame j'en suis sûr à
l'est puis voyez vous aussi autre chose
on n'a pas l'âge de ses parents elle est
trop vieux pour lui je sais bien si je
vois bien il s'ennuie avec nous et c'est
pas que nous dire mais tout fait perdre
votre temps non non
[Musique]
ah oui je voulais vous montrer
j'ai trouvé une photo dans ses affaires
est-ce que tenterait pas cette dame qui
a dû témoigner pour lui
ah je ne peux pas vous répondre
merci jm qui sont en lice mais c'est moi
oui passée la cabine oui c'est moi mais
il n'est pas ici je les ramenez moi même
à paris à près de chez lui porte de la
villette
je vous en prie
m gaillard
y'a mon mari qui vient d'appeler de leur
demander jusqu aux revenus de sortir là
je voulais parler à rené alors j'étais
obligée de lui dire il veut prévenir la
police
monsieur mais qu'est ce que vous faites
le jeu vous attendez et pourquoi n'êtes
vous pas rentrer chez vous allez finir
jour amène non mais bon comme vous
voudrez vous vous voulez pas m'aider
vous aider je veux retrouver mon père
quoi c'est un type formidable
ma mère dit que je ressemble un type
formidable qui a abandonné votre mère
quand vous êtes né c'est pas vrai mais
il savait pas il n'a jamais rien su et
est retourné dans son pays
oui il est australien mon père
un architecte
il était venu étudier à paris c'est
comme ça qu'ils sont connus mais s'ils
avaient su c'est sûr il serait resté se
serait marié avec elle
je dois pas être impossible de retrouver
quelqu'un en australie
stone
moi tout seul
[Musique]
c'est pour ça si vous pouviez m'aider
et pourquoi moi
à
je connais personne
et puis
peut-être qu'à ball en dirai plus qu'à
moi
qu'elle agit là où où il habitait
elle
et la même table une guerre son nom ce
qui prouve bien qu'elle tient pas
tellement est ce que vous le retrouviez
écoute moi bien erronée d'abord je suis
avocat je ne suis pas détective ni
généalogistes et quand bien même je le
serai tout une mineure je ne pourrais
pas entreprendre de démarches sont
accordés t par an et jusqu'à preuve du
contraire tes parents devant la loi ce
sont des parents adoptifs
mais je me fous de la loire
puis va avec
au milieu de toute cette viande je peux
plus les voir
corel j'aime bien c'est une vraie femme
enfin je les aime bien comme une grand
mère
oui
tenez pour vous dire j'avais 12 ans
quand j'ai su que j'étais un enfant
adopté il y en a ça leur fait un coup
d'apprendre ça et ben moi c'était le
plus beau jour de ma vie de savoir que
j'étais pas son fils quel royaume ont
adopté on va pas demander si je voulais
on choisit
pas moi
ne pas retourner là
mais arrêtez vous laissez moi les
centres si vous arrêtez pas à l'essai de
portières
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas le droit de me renie
tout ça parce que j'avais confiance en
lui
[Musique]
vous êtes bien comme les autres
qui c'est pas moi c'est la police qui te
ramènera c'est ça que tu veux faire
[ __ ] le camp
et pour aller où tu vas y on retrouvera
[Musique]
oui
allô allô
alors le premier coup
regardons vers le canal
héloise ont reçu par an dont un quart
briscoe sur blanc
vettier seul nom
alors quoi y'a personne qui va
[Musique]
alors guy cassiers quelqu'un je m'ai
fait la respiration d'un train de
reprendre conscience mais voilà on à
l'hôpital
les témoins vous restez là c'est vous
qui sait pas que ravageuse
tu connais normalement et puis tout d'un
coup il ya un chien qui a traversé la
rue j'ai voulu l'éviter j'ai pas pu
redresser
hier vous avez eu le parisien la photo
en première page
ça va lui faire la réclame à françois
que tu vous donc vos patates
oui en somme vous estimez que j'ai ne me
faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit
il est bien évident que rapporter les
faits tels qu'ils se sont déroulés vous
auriez placer ce jeune homme sous le
coup d'une inculpation gras remarquez je
comprends vos scrupules et n'empêche que
ce bruit autour de votre nom et bien non
je ne vais pas chercher un enchaînement
de circonstances a voulu que je sois mis
au courant de certains détails de la vie
de ce garçon qui me laissait pressentir
un drame j'ai essayé de l'éviter c'est
toi que vous ayez de bonnes raisons je
n'en doute pas mais votre rôle d'avocat
dans cette affaire était terminée
croyez moi il ya la sagesse c'est de
toujours rester dans le stricte limite
de notre métier pas impudence nous
n'avons à servir les intérêts d'un
client que dans la mesure où il nous en
charge en disant qu'en cette occasion je
n'ai pas agi en tant qu'avocat je me
suis engagée à titre personnel peut être
mais les suites malencontreuse portant
engagement personnel ont mis d'avocats
que vous êtes à la première page du
journal nous appeler
[Musique]
bonjour madame comment va rené aussi
bien que possible je suis passé à
l'hôpital ce matin il sortira demain si
j'avais su que les choses pouvaient en
arriver là
san jose a pas qu'on me reproche ce à un
jour on je crois que je devrais
m'éloigner pendant quelques temps qu'en
pensez vous c'est à vous de décider
je dois faire un voyage en grèce cet été
je vais avancer mon départ
allô oui y'a un ami qui m'a passé sa
facture devient alors c'est quoi ton
idée alors j'aurais pas dû dire ça parce
que c'est une idée en l'air
je me suis fait tellement des idées
toutes ces temps derniers
maintenant que tu as commencé en asie
nerveux comme il est plus montés contre
nous je me suis demandée ce n'est pas
revu sa mère tu penses que le nom tu
n'avais vu toi quand tu es nous avez
fait des ennuis
la reconnaîtrai doute ne serait pas elle
je trouvais ça non non non non je lui
ressemble pas leur origine ici
prenez non
[Musique]
fatigué par on m a tout raconté
d'ailleurs je l'avais reconnue et bien
alors vous en savez autant que moi oui
et quand même une chose je n'arrive pas
à y croire quand dans l'accident c'est
vrai que c'est lui qui a donné le coup
de volant répandre et 6
alors on en est là
il aimait mieux finir au fond du canal
que de revenir à la maison
oui c'est ce qui m'a dit faut-il qui me
détestent
qu'est-ce qui me reprochent il n'a
jamais manqué de rien il mordait pas aux
études je l'aimé à la boucherie
il n'a pas à s'en faire pour son avenir
le bifteck ça se vendra toujours pour un
bosquet au départ enfin oui ce que je
vais quand même pas mal non non tout
seul on lui montre la tête contre moi il
faut pas chercher plus loin
vous savez depuis quand ils se voient de
trois mois et avant tout allait pour le
mieux entre votre fils et vous n'empêche
qu'elle a sûrement une mauvaise
influence sur lui
alors voilà ce que vous allez faire vous
allez à trouver et vous allez lui dire à
votre avis il faut lui proposer combien
quoi trop bien quoi pour qu'on entende
plus parler d'elle donc je ne pense pas
que je ferai ce qu'il faudra je ne pense
pas qu'ils soient sensibles à cet
argument
ou qu'est ce que vous croyez il ya 15
ans quand elle a voulu nous le reprendre
l'argent sur la table 500 billets est
parti sans demander son reste
alors ça vous coûte rien d'essayer non
ne comptez pas sur moi moi voulait
encore pour l'autre jour vous ai fait
des excuses mais s'agit pas de ça je
voudrais que vous compreniez monsieur
chevillon en admettant que cette dame
consentent à s'éloigner pour le n'est
pas là le problème est entre votre fils
adoptif et vous l'important c'est qu'il
vous accepte comme son père
et là il faudrait peut-être que vous y
mettiez un peu du vôtre
de la c4
terroir
tu as vu quand on rentrait tout à faire
on perd notre temps ce matin
eca
peux tu en profites
le ton dimanche
apprendre quoi je te les donne
ou pas
sonné
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu m'as dit art matin que tu
étais très heureux avec nous j'y ai
repensé je sais reconnaître mais tort
quand il faut ça m'en faut reconnaître
aussi qu'il n'ya pas toujours me dis
tiens toi non plus enfin parlons pas du
passé ce qu'ils font c'est retarder ans
et du bon pied en vrai si tu es d'accord
moi je suis d'accord
[Musique]
dit quelque chose
tête de mule encore plus quatre chars
que moi c'est pour tous
[Musique]
c'est bien ce que tu penses je suis
qu'une brute
n'importe confiance en moi je vais te
montrer que tu te goures monte à 10 mois
quelque chose qui me ferait plaisir et
tu n'as pas bien quelque chose dont tu
as envie tu me le dis tu l'a tout de
suite mieux faire
qu'est ce que tu veux
retrouvez mon père
c'est vraiment ça que tu veux oui après
tout s'il faut en arriver là c'est
peut-être toac a raison
[Musique]
c'est là qu'elle habite
employés
bon bah on va s'asseoir je voulais te
dire quoi
oui ce que tu fais là
je voulais te dire merci
c'est son mari ça oui il est mort et lui
a laissé de quoi bonjour madame vous
devez vous demander ce qui nous amène
surtout moi on peut il se sent pris et
bien voilà madame je ne me serais pas
permis de vous déranger si c'était pas
pour faire plaisir à rené un oui on
parlait tous les deux ce matin et il me
disait qu'il avait retrouvé sa mère bien
content de l'avoir retrouvé message ou
l'apprends pas il me disait aussi qu'il
aimerait bien connaître son père dames
puisque vous allez commencer à lui en
parler il se pose des questions c'est
normal on joue on veut pas vous non plus
seulement fallait pas vous arrêter en
chemin il paraît que vous avez pas voulu
lui dire son nom
comment voulez-vous qu'il retrouve son
père s'il ne connaît pas son nom
et c'est ce qu'on est venu vous demander
à rené oui allez-y
amer faut pas vous gêner pour moi n'est
pas un moment puisqu'il vous le demande
citi a pas ce que vous faites là tu
viens toujours le même et motivé j'ai
pas le droit
[Musique]
e
non
vous
[Musique]
non
a voulu savoir
puis c
[Musique]
ah voilà où vous étiez passé vous savez
l'heure qu'il est adam savage
pourquoi m'aviez pas dit qu'est-ce qu'il
ya un
[Musique]
on se croit malin on se croit le plus
fort et puis un bonjour ça vous tombe
dessus
pourtant j'ai suis votre conseil mon
conseil d'y mettre un peu du mien pour
que rené m'accepte comme son père je
pensais que le mieux ce sera encore
qu'ils sachent la vérité c'est à dire
c'est en 53 j'ai connu denise denise la
faune madame haubourdin quoi elle avait
35 ans c'est ce que c'est on est un
homme on a envie de s'amuser un peu et
puis c'est pas pour la critiquer mais
était pas farouche non plus sa presse un
beau jour qu'est ce que vous voulez je
fasse j'étais marié j'avais rien à
reprocher à massa ne gèle pas divorcé
puis d'un autre côté ça faisait des
années qu'il me fallait pour qu'on
adopte un an sont alors je me suis dit
ben autant suis là qu'un autre au moins
chez dws c'est comme ça qu'on a adopté
rené ça vous paraît pas croyable ah ça
je vous avoue qu as est elle mieux non
de toutes façons de nice voulait pas le
garder alors quand j'ai su que c'était
un garçon julie van tu le mets
l'assistance et dois je le prends ni vu
ni connu
eh ben vous croirez si vous voulez il
encore salut je lui donne de l'argent et
vous avez raconté tout ça rené
comment at il réagi se porte tellement
lui c'est surtout ma femme
pourquoi
elle ne le savait pas non comme le lui
avait pas dit au moment de l'adoption
[Musique]
non mais pourquoi faut comprendre je
voulais être
comment vous expliquez que je voulais
qu'ils soient autant son fils que le
mien pendant des années ça a été comme
ça et puis hier soir or sur le moment
rien dit
s'est contenté pleurer c'est tout
ce matin
sa lettre
est parti
vous allez pas me laisser tomber fait ça
pour moi allez l'avoir sait même pas où
elle est allée voilà sûrement été dans
sa famille son frère à une exploitation
dans l'oise mais je peux vous y conduit
non croyez moi ce sera beaucoup mieux de
lui parler vous mêmes veulent me coûtera
pas vous savez parler c'est votre métier
lesquels lui dire je sais pas moi que
france c'est parfois comme ça au bout de
30 ans mariage que sa place est à la
maison si elle revient pas pour moi ils
le fassent au moins pour rené il a
demandé
non
non non ma place est plus là bas il à
son père il à sa mère moi je suis de
trop mais pourquoi dites vous ça d'abord
légalement il est votre fils dont la loi
la loi sa dispose des gens sur le papier
et les sentiments sont sûrs de rien
qu'est ce que vous voulez maintenant je
pourrais pas me sortir de l'idée qu'il
est plus à mon mari qu'à moi non j'ai
plus ma place
il est là vous ne voulez pas lui parler
a menti pendant des années
mais justement il a cru bien faire et
vous les prenez soin autant votre enfant
que le sien a pas être confiant sambre
pourtant je vous jure et serait venu à
moi en me disant c'est mon fils je leur
accueil et comme le mil balle est encore
temps c'est maintenant qu'il voulait
même
la vie vous savez monsieur recommence
[Musique]
sonné
elle t'a dit de mal d'avoir qui tout à
l'heure
faut pas juger trop vite rennais
comme sa première vue j'ai peut-être
pour le bol ne mangez pas attendu 18 ans
pour m'occuper de toi tu rêves qui l'a
élevé qui a trimé pour assurer tant
d'avenir l'oublient pas
maintenant je te retiens d'ipod search
fois où j'en suis on marche pourrait
alors comme l'a dit j'ai la loi pour moi
et je le serai pas si tu veux aller
vivre avec elle tu es libre d'un autre
côté si tu choisi de rester avec moi et
j'y compte bien un débat tu le
regretteras poste elle dit parce qu'ici
c'est du solide
et ici tu es chez toi c'est ce que je
voulais te dire
[Musique]
oui
où
mais
[Musique]
et
hamon
[Musique]
je viens chercher la mairie n'est pas là
oui bah c'est ce qu'on va voir
[Musique]
non
c'est lui qui vous a demandé de me
prévenir non c'est votre femme cette
fois de grandes passions je crois vous
ne pouvez plus rien monsieur rien qu'a
choisi
[Musique]
oui
voilà j'en avais fini avec la faire je
viens j'avais le sentiment d'un temps un
beau gâchis
enfin tout ça aurait pu être pire au
bout du compte
je ne regrettait pas ce que j'avais fait
c'est moi vous dérangeait pas
[Musique]
surprise nous attendait pas vraiment
tiré du téléphone et en face on fait
rien je vais descendre au sud etc non
non non non te dérange pas je mange ce
qu'il pense à toi
[Musique]
alors ça va toi
ouais mais ça n'a pas de bon sens non
non non je vais pas je envie d'être avec
vous c'est tout
et ben non puisque les bizuths
[Rires]
allez
[Musique]
je ne
à
[Musique]